désigné ce n'est pas moi qui le
souhaitaient les défauts de défendre ils
m'ont sollicité j'ai été désigné par
monsieur pavlin ce qui est le parquet
s'y oppose et ce qui est encore une fois
une mesure qui est extrêmement rare et
qu'il n'est pas acceptable
14e ce qui a assumé son geste il a tenté
de l'expliquer c'est assez difficile
dans le contexte actuel c'est un geste
qui était mûri réfléchi on peut avoir un
accord ou en désaccord avec ce geste mon
travail en tant qu'avocat auprès de lui
a été de m'assurer qu'ils leur
respectait le droit qui ne prenait pas
de risques inconsidérés et qu'à partir
de là on est tenté d'insinuer sans le
moindre fondement que j'aurais été
impliqué dans cette affaire me semble
d'une indignité absolue non pas du fait
de l'atteinte à ma réputation mais de
l'atteinte aux droits de la défense